Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
It's a new week and a new episode!
Our 94th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today!
And for some Ruffians that might be new... How did you get here?
Right.
I don't know.
Probably by rolling out of bed.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
It's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Mococo sounding better, right?
But you're gonna rest a lot more, right?
Cause this week is a fluffy week.
Fluffy week!
Pero Sighting deshita.
You know Pero was really busy last week doing translations and RSJSJP subbed by, but... I guess not.
I guess Ruffians... Pero, you didn't see him?
I guess you must be tired after all the events going on.
He did help us and you know the Ruffians out with all the translations.
Doing our streams together with our JP-senpai.
So you know both his brains and his wings.
It must be tired from all the speed typing.
Right, right.
Pero's gone missing.
I don't know if it's missing.
Or maybe, you know, he's just kind of all holed up in whatever he wants to hold up in.
Doing his thing!
Yeah, he's just sleeping and maybe taking some time for himself.
Vacation.
BAU BAU!
Keep your eyes open, okay?
Don't get close.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Maybe one thing that comes to mind first is... FUWAMOCO!
We started our Minecraft journey!
BAU BAU!
We started from having our very little knowledge of Minecraft.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Today I'm losing them all because of Fuwawa!
And then you're having a legend?
Cobblestone house now!
Yeah, we did!
Slowly but surely learning!
Yeah!
I know!
Fuwawa didn't even know that we had the iron tools.
I thought they were just like a... Not iron, just like a rock.
They're not rocks?
I worked hard for them and then you lost them.
How did you make the iron?
I got iron and then you...
I wanna get ironed.
Yeah, there's been some bumps along the way, but Ruffians, I think, you know, we're in good paws because we have you there together with us.
It's definitely a different experience, you know, having us play and stream separately on different computers.
What did you think, Ruffians?
Yeah.
It's a bit different, huh?
Did you like hearing our voices this early in the background?
It was fun, it was cool!
You were confused!
It was a good experience!
A bit laggy?
That's YouTube's fault, maybe.
Yeah, we'll be better split-screen.
We looked into the office!
It's not as easy as you think and that it might be hard to see everything.
There's a lot going on in my head.
Because we were thinking that would be fun too, right?
But it's not possible.
Yeah.
We did really try.
Really, really?
Yeah.
But you know what?
I made a couple funny sounds during Minecraft too.
Yeah, I did too, right?
Right?
Wait, which one?
Um...
That one.
The squeaky toy sound at the end.
I don't know.
It just happens.
I don't mean that seagull sound that you make too, Moco-chan.
I don't know, it's way too high!
Yeah, but we had a lot of fun.
We're looking forward to improving and learning how to play Minecraft more.
Yeah, it's probably going to take us a while to learn, but we're up to the challenge!
Please look forward to more, okay?
After FUWAMO week, okay Ruffians?
Not this week, but hopefully next week.
BAU BAU!
You know Golden Week, we did a bunch of things.
We had our first collab with Watame-senpai!
BAU BAU!
We are so so super happy to be able to play together.
We played Co-op House games all together.
We really wanted to show everybody, you know, we're FUWAMOCO!
We're fluffy and fuzzy!
We're the top fluff!
We're demon dogs!
Watame-senpai, she's just a sheep.
But... We got pulverized instead.
The squeal is...
We're seventeen.
It's the winner being Watame-senpai!
She's a strong sheep, okay?
Because, you know, we lost and we lost really badly.
There was a bit of a punishment, right, Moco-chan?
Chu-chu time.
Yeah, chu-chu time.
So, yeah, the collab might have ended with some chu-chu-chus over in Watame-senpai's direction.
Yeah.
But it was a bunch of fun, right?
Yeah!
Who knew that was amazing?
We're playing so amazing at darts and boxing and so many games.
Right.
We didn't start the chat.
What was that steak one?
Yeah.
But we really hope that we can play more games together with her soon.
And also!
Watame-senpai also just released her own version of the hololive Ierukana 2024 version.
Do you remember it, Ruffians?
It was released during Expo earlier in March.
But you can check out Watame-senpai's version over on her channel.
And you'll definitely want to go take a look because Watame-senpai cosplays with every hololive member
Including Fuwamoco!
It's really cute!
And you know, there's some super cute details in the art too.
Like you know, Fauna-senpai's pattern on her skirt is now changed to do-do-do.
And lots of stuff like that, so see if you can catch them all, okay?
I've seen them all too, right?
BAU BAU!
Catch them all!
Save them all!
It's hololive ieru kana?
Not the other ieru kana?
No.
Kinda sounds like it, especially when you catch them all.
No, not like that.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
Moco-chan.
Ruffians.
I know I was busy with Golden Week.
What?
Did you notice?
Huh?
Hi!
Well... All of a sudden... After Shiori's birthday!
Yeah!
Nerissa showed up!
BAU BAU!
They had a sleepover party together!
I don't know what's going on, but maybe... Is this a birthday present to Shiori from Nerissa?
The rain's blue.
They should've talked about a bunch of funny stuff, huh?
Funny stuff.
Yeah.
I know I should've played one, but I... You know, I... I hope they had a lot of fun.
But that was us.
That was us.
Huh?
Not jealous at all.
Yeah.
No.
Absolutely not.
Yeah.
Maybe soon.
One day.
I will be looking forward to what happens in the future.
Yeah.
We're just gonna have to put those jealous feelings aside.
Jealous feelings!
Sad.
BAU BAU!
You had time with Nerissa already?
Not enough!
Have you ever spent time with Nerissa?
It's never enough.
I guess you could say that about Moco-chan too.
Really?
Yeah, because we spend a lot of time together and I still haven't gotten annoyed of you.
You sure?
Okay, now I am.
BAU BAU!
While Golden Week it was filled with a bunch of firsts, first collabs, but... On top of that, we ate a new food!
Yeah, a new food.
One that's maybe a bit surprising.
Do you have any ideas, Ruffians?
Mayonnaise pondering?
I don't know what that classifies as a food.
I've had onions before and I know what I like and don't like.
And that's not onions.
Okonomiyaki, we had that.
Okona, I like okona.
Saba miso!
I haven't had that before.
Jingisukanaiya.
Oh, Pufferface, Fugu, Fuwamoco, we're not that kind of demon dog.
But!
You know we met with Koyori-senpai from our off club, right?
She gave us a bunch of cup noodles to try out!
BAU BAU for me!
You know, actually, FUWAMOCO, we've never ever eaten cup noodles before.
So we were really curious and really happy to try them!
You know what?
Despite being in a cup, like a styrofoam cup, they were really, really, really good!
You know, Mama Puppy, she always said that no Fuwamoco, you can't eat them.
So that's why we didn't really have any.
But these, you know, they have meat and seafood and veggies in them.
So they should be good, right?
They were good!
It was a bit mysterious, though.
The meat, right?
What kind of meat are you?
It doesn't matter.
I could see bits of octopus in it, though, and seafood, right?
Yeah, it was really, really yummy!
But, you know, Koyori-senpai, she had a favorite one.
So we decided to save that one for last.
And that was the milk seafood.
I really liked that one.
I liked it so much that I even drank the soup from the bottom of it.
I don't know if you're supposed to do that.
I don't know either!
I felt a little bit guilty doing it.
But they really, really helped us out so much during a busy Golden Week.
So we're really, really grateful to Koyori-senpai for all the helpful notes.
It was nice to have something warm for my barker, too.
We had so many flavors, right?
What do you think was the best one, Moco-chan?
Your favorite flavor.
They were all really good, but I think I liked the curry flavor one the best.
It was comfy!
And it wasn't in the curry flavor, but I also liked the little yellow bits.
The egg, maybe?
In some of them, yeah.
It sort of reminded me of eating little chickies.
Hiyoko-chan.
Like they have little faces on them, because they're really fluffy.
Yeah, I think curry was my favorite flavor too.
Didn't you like the milk tea flavor?
I liked the milk tea food, but the curry was really good too.
It was really comfy.
They're both really good.
Thank you Koyori-senpai!
We are able to survive Golden Week because of Koyori-senpai's noodles.
BAU BAU!
Why not try eating curry next?
We have been having curry.
Like just normal curry, not without the noodles.
We have!
It's yummy!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, there's been some news.
In case you haven't heard it, though.
Us, FUWAMOCO, we have an unofficial rival.
Yeah.
And, you know, his name, sometimes, it's hard to remember.
What?
It's always such a poor memory.
It's Kevin Lamar.
Yeah.
Apparently, he released a new song or something recently.
Something?
Yeah.
A few days ago we took a listen.
You know what?
We couldn't help but notice, but... He says BAU BAU BAU!
What the heck?
BAU BAU RUN!
What do you think, Ruffians?
BAU BAU BAU!
No way!
Right!
Challenge!
Yeah.
I don't know.
The eyes of FUWAMOCO.
That's what it sounds like.
He's a bit scared.
Yeah.
He's shaking, huh?
He's sleepy.
Yeah.
No.
When you've been going dogs?
BAU BAU BAU!
We've been around for 2,000 years now!
We're no puppies anymore!
No!
We're fine!
We're all puppies!
Yeah!
Morning!
BAU BAU!
BAU
And so, just like Moco-chan's been doing regularly, she's gonna challenge herself to something new, which would be natto.
But, FUWAMOCO's been busy and hasn't really been able to go to the store, and I ate all the natto!
So, today, Moco-chan, you're gonna be challenging yourself
Umeboshi!
Umeboshi is kind of similar to natto.
You can have them for breakfast, and they're pickled flowers.
They're not fermented, they're pickled, which is kind of the same.
And they're really healthy for you.
And they're a very traditional Japanese food.
I'm the delicious one.
There is a normal one.
But, they are also very, very super, super, supai.
Sour.
Sour!
Yeah, you couldn't find the word.
I couldn't find the word.
Yeah, and this time they don't, no, no, no umeshu.
No alcohol related.
Can you open the container?
I'll try it too.
Hey!
What was that?
Hi!
The container sounds so weird!
It's pretty good!
They're real!
It just made a weird sound.
Hi!
I got the best ones I could get.
These ones!
The farmers who worked hard to make these ones.
Look at them.
They're in Wakayama-ken.
Wakayama Perfection.
Not United States.
Not the United States.
Not Tochigi.
Wakayama-ken.
Yeah.
And they're really really red.
And wrinkly.
And they smell so good.
They smell good.
What does it say on the packaging?
They have shiso.
Shiso.
Shiso leaves in them.
On top.
They have a very...
Beautiful smell.
That's what makes these umeboshi good.
So Moco-chan, you're going to challenge yourself to eat an umeboshi.
And then I'm going to challenge myself to eat a chibikasame.
Okay, Moco-chan!
First, we'd like to say thank you to the farmers in Wakayama Prefecture.
Okay, Moco-chan.
It's really soft.
Sometimes it's crunchy umeboshi too, right?
Like snack ones.
Moco-chan, careful, there's a seed inside.
Don't choke on the seed, okay?
Moco-chan.
It's not that sour.
What?
It could be more sour.
But umeboshi is so yummy.
I really want to try making them myself.
How does it taste?
Moco-chan.
Yummy.
Yummy?
Sour?
Not really.
Is it like a plum flavor to it?
No.
Like a...
What would you have it with?
With rice?
Sure?
Sure, that's a usable way.
I think you could put it on toast.
Toast?
Like a jam?
Oh, like a jam?
Crunch the seed!
No way!
If there's a crunch sound, that would be Moco-chan losing her teeth.
Demon dog teeth are strong, but not that strong!
No way!
Ah...
Yum.
I'm gonna have one too.
They're really really big.
It's really wrinkly.
But not that sour.
It's yummy!
It's good.
I feel like they're very big though.
You finished it already?
Did you eat another?
Really?
That's it.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, make sure you try umeboshi too, okay?
Yummy!
Maybe you can let us know how sour it was to you.
It's not that sour.
It's good.
But, I feel like...
I really go by sour food.
Except for the soup that I made you, huh?
I don't want to eat sour soup, you know?
BAU BAU!
Make sure to challenge yourself to extra challenges after something difficult, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO-chan has had two irregular corners.
Yes!
She is our Doggie of the Day.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Rion!
Why?
Are you surprised because you're on FUWAMOCO Morning right now, Rion?
I can't believe I'm on FUWAMOCO Morning!
Is that why your face is like this, Koi?
Yeah, but I can understand though.
I'd be surprised if...
If, you know, I was on FUWAMOCO, I'd be surprised just like him.
So cute, right?
So cute!
Leon!
Leon's a good boy filled with energy!
I can see the energy.
Energy!
Even though he makes crazy faces like this, he's actually pretty quiet and doesn't bark all that much.
Good boy.
He's just having fun when he has fun.
Yep.
How does Leon BAU BAU?
Maybe like BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
I think just like that.
Especially I can hear that now when I look at the picture of Leon.
That's how it is.
Leon's very cute and very fluffy.
And also Leon gets just as surprised as Fuwamoco gets when we're playing horror games.
It makes sense.
Hopefully he's a little bit more brave than us and doesn't run away with his tail between his legs.
Why are you saying it like that's what we do?
BAU BAU!
Who is this?
Who is?
Hi!
No, that's Leon!
BAU BAU!
Hi!
Ruffians, you've been making sure to stretch out those paws, right?
Let's see where you went on a walk this time for us.
Today, I went on a walk!
Yay!
Where did we go?
De-den!
Dangerous walk.
What for?
We're still getting better around them.
Mainly thanks to Nerissa.
But these ones here, they're particularly dangerous.
Just because it looks like a slipper doesn't mean you should try it on, okay?
You might lose your whole foot.
Not just a few toes.
The whole foot gone.
Just, you know, ignore it and continue on your day, okay?
No matter how curious you are, okay?
Even if you think it might be soft inside and squishy, it's not a good slipper.
No.
Just us, okay?
Yeah.
We haven't tried.
We hope you had a good one.
Good walk and a good walk.
Hopefully you're feeling better too.
BAU BAU!
Now for our Question of the Day!
We have de-den!
Oh!
Pass along my thanks to Pero, whose full-length name surprised me by being spelled Peroncino.
For the live translation!
Has known Japanese all this time.
Did he perhaps mentor you in it?
Though he's just a pet.
Will you do more live translations in the future?
Wow.
You see, Pero's incredibly fast at typing and translating because of his wings.
But, you know, when it comes to spelling his name... We all have things that we're not great at, right?
Yeah, right.
It can be spelling problems.
That's okay.
But Pero hasn't known Japanese all the time, actually.
He actually picked it up when...
I lost him in a Japanese textbook while we were doing guide dog training in Japan.
Definitely not on purpose.
Right!
Not on purpose!
Yeah, it wasn't because, you know, we got tired of his yapping and... No!
Well... Yeah... And, uh... Then, you know, after that, I guess him being an old demon dog and everything...
That was the way, the best way, for him to be able to pick it up.
You know, it was really interesting seeing all the kanji and hiragana all over him too.
Yeah, he literally picked it all up.
As for in the future though, it would be really helpful for all of us.
Especially Ruffians who are still just learning Japanese.
So we really hope that Pero will be there more for live translations.
But I think that's up to Pero and Fuwawa.
The kind of mood he's in, right?
Whether he thinks the Ruffians deserve it or not.
Probably if he's missing or not.
We'll make sure to ask lots of questions!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
We're always looking, so just use the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
Send us your Pero Sighting, your questions, your works, your doggies, okay?
I say this every time.
Okay, Ruffians?
I say it every time.
We're waiting!
BAU BAU!
As for our next stream, let's take a look at the schedule.
Our schedule!
We have dogs organized neatly.
I'm gonna be organizing some dogs.
Minus Moco-chan.
All on my own.
And I think I won't just be organizing them neatly.
I'm hoping to organize them vertically as well.
So, I'm gonna try a bunch of things.
It's a little fresh fluffy flow.
So, hopefully you can join me because I'm good at organizing, but I have never organized dogs.
So, we'll see.
BAU BAU.
And after that, well, we have Moco-chan will be here beside me for FUWAMOCO Morning this week.
But you're gonna be doing a lot of resting, right?
Resting.
I'm gonna be sleeping.
Not just resting.
Sleeping.
And in between that, I'm gonna be also playing Touhou Fujinroku Mountain of Faith.
We played it with Marisencho-senpai, but I wanna do some practicing.
I wanna show I can do it too.
So that's what I'm gonna do.
And then Hitman Ruffians!
You really seem like you wanted me to play this game, so I'm gonna do my best!
I'm gonna become Fuwawa the Hitman.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
And then a little bit of a peek into our
Ruffi-huwawa week!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
For those of you who are joining us through the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO alert!
It's BAU BAU Cup Noodles!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Patchlinda!
BAU BAU!
Sakupaisen!
Sakuya!
BAU BAU!
Kiki!
Nobiru!
BAU BAU!
Kiss!
Fantastic!
BAU BAU!
Yamai!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!